humans will always be curious about
whether or not we have galactic
neighbors and if they would be our
friends or foes maybe the answers are in
the stars or in secret government files
until we know the truth we have some
great movies on Netflix about alien
visitors minor spoilers ahead have you
ever had a nightmare that comes true if
so you might be intrigued by the premise
of the film extinction that's exactly
what happens to Peter who begins having
bad dreams about an invading force that
comes to earth threatening the safety of
his family and everything he holds dear
little does he know that these
disturbing nightmares would actually
turn out to be premonitions when he
visits a psychiatrist to get to the root
of these dreams he encounters another
patient who's been suffering from the
same night terrors and he begins to
wonder if there is something bigger
going on what if something bad is coming
and - select assignment unfortunately
Peter suspicions proved to be correct
one night
spaceships suddenly descend upon the
city and attack Peter and his wife
managed to snag a weapon from one of the
invading soldiers and Peter utilizes the
knowledge from his visions to protect
his family but his understanding of
what's actually happening can only get
them so far Peter is about to discover
that he was receiving these visions for
a reason and when he finds out why the
knowledge turns his life upside down a
road trip with friends goes very very
wrong in the signal three MIT students
Jonah
Nick and Haley are driving all the way
across the United States Haley is
relocating to California and the guys
are coming along to help out with the
move Nick worries that Haley's new life
will complicate his relationship with
her however all of these troubles will
soon fade into the background when the
trio is faced with a much more dire
threat as the three friends settle into
their hotel room for the night they
discovered that a hacker named Nomad has
been tracking them and found their
location this isn't their first run-in
with the hacker nomads
almost got them expelled back at MIT
when they were accessing the school's
private servers Nick and Jonah decide to
get back at Nomad by tracking the
hackers location and heading to the
abandoned house where he is supposedly
hiding out when they arrived they find
nothing but when Haley is suddenly
pulled into the sky it becomes obvious
that the group is
Dumbledore to their strange new
surroundings and save the woman he loves
in revolt an American Special Forces
soldier wakes up in a jail cell but no
clear idea of who he really is
after being knocked out in a battle
against invading robotic machines that
have taken over the world he's developed
amnesia another prisoner Nadya gives him
the nickname Bo tries to help him fill
in the blanks she's a former French a
doctor and explains that the two of them
were captured by a criminal gang and
have been kept as prisoners ever since
Nadia also informs him about
otherworldly attackers [ __ ] with the
invasion not who what although Bo
doesn't remember much about his
encounter with these futuristic machines
he discovers that the incident left him
with a special ability he can absorb and
discharge electricity Nadia and Bo
escaped together and decide to take the
chances in the outside world their plan
is to make their way to Bo's former
military base in Nairobi where he was
serving prior to his capture but the
machines have already wiped out every
major city on the planet and their
journey to the base will be more
dangerous than any human warfare they've
ever experienced a sequel to 2010's
skyline which followed survivors of an
alien invasion of Los Angeles beyond
skyline explores another story taking
place at the same time as the original
movie in this film Los Angeles police
detective Mark Corley helps his son
Trent get out of jail just as the
invasion begins mark and Trent are
estranged but mark couldn't stand to
leave his son behind as most of the
residents of LA are sucked up into
various spaceships by huge beams of
light
mark leads a group of stray survivors
through the subway tunnels to the marina
hoping to escape somewhere safe but of
course their plan doesn't work out the
way they had hoped when they finally
make it to the marina they're captured
by the alien flagship and that's when
the real adventure begins what's
actually happening inside these ships
and what do these creatures want from
human beings mark is about to stumble on
some truly disturbing answers if you're
watching a film that involves aliens and
you see bright lights appear in the sky
it usually indicates that someone is
about to be abducted at first like takes
different approach to this trope when
Alex leaves a bonfire party with a guy
she's interested in they walked through
the woods to a nearby lake to spend some
time alone
the next thing she knows bright lights
appear over her as she floats helplessly
in the water when she regains
consciousness she's walking down a
country road but no idea what happened
to her Alex wasn't abducted but
something about her has changed she'll
soon realize that she's gained the
ability to move objects with her mind
after finding a ride back into town she
calls up her friend Sean who also
happens to have a crush on her Alex
experiments with her newfound abilities
and Sean stays by your side even when
the authorities start tracking her down
with some similarities to stranger
things fans at the popular Netflix
series will definitely want to check out
at first light with cell phones and
cameras being such a big part of our
lives these days what would happen if
aliens were to attack earth chances are
the invasion would be caught on film by
pretty much everybody that's the basic
concept explored in the darkest dawn
which is a sequel to the 2014 found
footage film Hungerford when Chloe is
given a video camera on her 16th
birthday her first videos featuring your
family are funny and light-hearted that
is until the world as she knows it comes
crashing down when an alien invasion
begins in Europe things become even more
confusing and gruesome when Chloe
realizes that the aliens are taking over
the bodies of human beings through it
all she documents her experiences and
keeps a video journal for her missing
mother I'm gonna show you how strong
your daughter can be as chaos and
violence erupts around her Chloe's main
goal is to protect her sister and if
possible find a place where they can
finally be safe Scarlett Johansson stars
as a beautiful and terrifying alien
life-form in under the skin in fact she
wears her human disguise so well that
men can't help but be seduced by her she
travels around Scotland managing to pick
up one man after another but she's not
looking for love as she leads guys into
an abandoned home it becomes clear that
she's some sort of predator to her men
are nothing but prey and to make things
even scarier she's not working alone
under the skin is definitely not your
usual alien flick it's the kind of
brilliant film that
you might see in an art house theater
and there are moments that will make
your skin crawl the cinematography is
somehow gorgeous and unsettling at the
same time and Johansson's performance is
eerie and enthralling the film explores
the question what it really means to be
human and that's what makes it stand out
among the genre why did NASA really
cancel the Apollo 18 mission to the moon
the found footage film Apollo 18
suggests an alternate theory
maybe it wasn't cancelled after all
maybe the astronauts really did go up to
the moon on a top-secret mission that
was hidden from the public and this is
the lost footage from that ill-fated
journey
it's December of 1973 and the crew of
Apollo 18 has just found out they will
actually be working on a secret project
for the Department of Defense their
voyage to the moon will be disguised as
a satellite launch and the public will
never know that they left the Earth's
atmosphere but when the crew finally
lands on the moon they begin hearing
strange noises outside of their module
and when they stumble across the body of
a long-lost Soviet cosmonaut they're
more than ready to head home but the
moon might not be so lifeless after all
and these unlucky astronauts could end
up staying a lot longer than they
bargained for in the Australian sci-fi
film occupation a small town in the
outback comes under attack from an
unknown alien force a group of civilians
makes it their mission to band together
and avoid being captured by their
attackers Matt and his girlfriend Amelia
both work hard at their jobs and make
just enough to get by in their rural
community the highlight of Matt's week
is always the weekend football game
where he gets to face off against his
local rival Jackson but out of the blue
their usual game is interrupted by an
alien invasion and the group flees into
the woods grabbing as many of their
neighbors as they can once they arrive
at a somewhat safe hideaway the
frightened and confused collective must
learn how to live and work with one
another in addition to Matt and Amelia
the group includes a pregnant nurse and
ex-con and a farmer who knows the land
like the back of his hand after
discovering a possible weakness in the
invaders they begin training themselves
to fight back what's the plan cause the
destruction breaking people out and save
the planet
that's the plan however with violent
aliens everywhere the basic question is
can this ragtag team adapt survive and
defeat
highly advanced and seemingly
unstoppable enemy Cloverfield is
probably one of the best-known found
footage films about an alien invasion in
this 2008 movie HUD is helping to set up
a surprise party for his friend Rob he's
handed a camera so he can film everyone
giving testimonials and wishing Rob good
luck on his upcoming move from New York
City to Japan during the party Rob
becomes upset when his ex-girlfriend
Beth shows up with another guy so he
goes out on the fire escape to get some
air as Rob's brother and HUD tried to
cheer him up the building is rocked by
what seems to be an earthquake forget
the world and hang on to the people that
you care about the most
the partygoers head outside to
investigate and HUD captures the
subsequent catastrophe on film the
Statue of Liberty's severed head rolls
down the street as panic breaks out
everyone soon discovers that an enormous
monster is loose in the city and
destroying everything in its path plus
smaller parasitic creatures are leaping
off the monsters body to attack anyone
within striking distance soon Rob HUD
and their friends are on a mission to
save Beth and escape New York City
however the gigantic monster has some
plans of its own it definitely seems
like most Alien movies predict tragic
consequences if earth ever gets a visit
from extraterrestrials but that doesn't
mean an alien invasion flick can't be
funny in the sci-fi comedy evolution a
group of scientists researches
microscopic alien life that came to
earth when a meteor crashed in the
Arizona desert to the untrained eye the
findings from their samples might seem
unremarkable after all they're only
looking at simple organisms but as
college professors IRA and Harry soon
discover these organisms are multiplying
so rapidly they begin evolving into more
advanced life-forms overnight when the
government catches wind of what's going
on the army bands IRA and Harry from the
crash site other scientists steal all of
their research and samples forcing IRA
and Harry to take matters into their own
hands when they finally manage to break
in they discovered that the lab is
bursting with new life forms and with
aliens escaping to the outside world
they decide to find the creatures before
it's too late
of course since this is a comedy IRA
Harry and their newfound associates have
plenty of unexpected and entertaining
adventures as they do their best to save
the world check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about movies on Netflix are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]